saving a family after death three
urns all belonging to the same family
were found abandoned at a senior living
facility
two of the deceased are veterans after
someone suggested throwing them away a
community is coming together to make
sure they make it to their final resting
place with full military honors
victoria saha has the story you will
only see
for more than a year and a half the
remains of stella
her husband theodore and their son
ernest stayed abandoned at the clark
towers assisted living
after their other son who was holding
onto his family's ashes
died apartment manager tammy wilpe found
the urns tucked away in a closet for
decades
but quickly realized there was no other
family to hand them over to i would
never be able to throw them away
i couldn't not knowing what to do she
called reverend grace thompson for help
when i called los angeles because these
three are from los angeles
and the cremains were actually um
the bodies were actually processed in
los angeles they couldn't help me either
and i was told three times in los
angeles to throw them away
with a little bit of digging they found
out theodore and his son ernest were
veterans
i'm so honored to say i'm their
guardians
from the veterans cemetery which means
that
i'm responsible for them and i really
took that
seriously to make sure that my
three urns had a proper burial
but their mom stella was not going to be
allowed to be buried with them
unless someone paid a 450 dollar fee
we wanted them to be together they were
in life and they needed to be in death
so the veterans of foreign war groups
stepped in to help with the funds
it was a no-brainer for us
we did bring it up at our meeting on the
12th of june
and the entire post voted voted to do
that
the family of three urns will be laid to
rest together with full military honors
on july 13
at the veterans cemetery in boulder city
victoria saha
8 news now nice ending there
as for the apartment manager tammy wilpe
she told her residents to let her know
if they have urns
and who to give them to in the event of
their passing
additionally reverend thompson's church
came up with a program called from womb
to tomb that offers guidance on
abandoned urns